- We've spent several
videos now getting familiar
with the Lorentz transformations.
What I want to do now, instead
of thinking of what X prime
and C T prime is in terms of X and C T,
I wanna think about, what
is the change in X prime
and the change in C T prime
going to be in terms of
change in X and change in C T.
And we'll see it's just
going to involve some
fairly straight-forward
algebraic manipulation.
So, let's think about it.
Change in X prime is going to be
X prime final minus
X prime initial.
Well, X prime final,
let me just pick a
suitable color for that,
X prime final is going to be
gamma times X final
minus beta times C T final.
All I did is use this formula up here.
If I want to figure out my final X prime,
I'm just going to think of
my final X and my final C T.
So, that's that.
And from that, I'm going to
subtract the initial X prime.
Well, X prime initial is just going to be,
let me get another color here,
Lorentz factor gamma times X initial
minus beta times C T initial.
So, now, let's see, we
can factor out the gamma,
so this is going to be equal to,
and I'll do it in my color for gamma.
If we factor out the
gamma, we're gonna get
gamma times, we're gonna have X final,
let me do this in a,
so we have, do that in white actually.
We're gonna have X final,
and then if we distribute
this negative sign, minus X initial,
and then, let's see,
if we distribute this negative
sign, well, I don't want
to skip too many steps
here, so that's that.
And then we're going to have
negative beta C T final,
and then we have plus, we
distributed this negative,
plus beta C T initial
and so what can we do here,
well this, that's just
going to be change in X.
So I can rewrite this as being equal to
gamma times change in X...
Let me factor out a negative beta.
So I'l say, minus beta times,
well then you're going to have C T final
minus C T initial.
And what's C T final minus C T initial?
I think I'm skipping
too many steps already.
Well that's just going
to be change in C T.
So we get, this is all
going to be equal to
gamma, our Lorentz
factor, times change in X
minus beta times change in C T.
And since C isn't changing,
it could also be viewed
as C times change in T, either way.
So, there you have it.
Notice, it takes almost
the exact same form.
X prime is equal to gamma
times X minus beta C T
and change in X prime is going to be gamma
times change in X minus
beta time change in C T.
And, I'm not going to do it in this video,
but you can make the exact same algebraic
argument for your change in C T prime,
as you'll see and I encourage
you to do this on your own,
change in C T prime, which
you could also view as,
since C isn't changing,
C times delta T prime,
these are equivalent,
is going to be equal to
gamma times change in C T
minus beta times change in X,
and I encourage you,
right after this video,
actually do this one too.
Delta X prime is going to be X prime final
minus X prime initial and
then do what I just did here,
just a little algebraic manipulation.
You can make the same
exact argument over here
to get to the result
that I just wrote down.
You see, well our change
in C T prime is going to be
C T prime final minus C T
prime initial and then you can
substitute with this, do
a little bit of algebraic
manipulation and you'll
get that right over there.
And the whole reason I'm doing this is,
well now, we can think in terms of change
in the coordinates, which will allow us to
think about what velocities would be
in the different frames of reference,
which is going to be pretty neat.